موت بالزلازل المدمره يتلو موتا بالعواصف
الثلجيه بعد موت بالاسلحه الفتاكه
والسوريون كالمعتاد في صداره قوافل
الضحايا يستغيثون دون كبير امل بامكانيه
نجدتهم او تخليصهم من هذه السلسله الرهيبه
في عالم طالما اتهموه بانه تصرف على مدى
اثنتي عشره سنه داميه كانها اعتاد رؤيتهم
يذبحون
هم قالوا في وقت مبكر من العقد الماضي
قولتهم الجماعيه الشهيره ملنا غيرك يا
الله كنايه عن يقينهم بان حسابات المصالح
على المستوى الدولي كما الاقليمي اقتضى
تركهم لمصيرهم دون ماء اي محاولات جاده
لانقاذهم وما كان احد يتوقع حينئذ ان
تكتمل اشاحه البشريه بصرها عن نكبتهم
بوقوع كوارث طبيعيه واجيولوجيه تقتل الوف
الناجين الذين سبق لهم ان استطاعوا الفرار
من كوارث اسواء كانت اسفرت عن مقتل مئات
الالوف منهم صحيح انهم الان ليسوا وحدهم
وان ملايين الاتراك معهم في مهب العاصفه
الزلداديه الجديده لكن الساعات الطويله
القاسيه التي مرت منذ زلزله الارض زلزالها
على جانبي الحدود بين البلدين المنكوبين
ظلت وما زالت تؤكد تباعا على كون هؤلاء
اللاجئين والنازحين من بينهم هم الاضعف
قدره والاقل حيل في محاولاتهم اليائسه
لانتشال ذويهم احياء او موتى من تحت انقاض
المباني المدمره لقد اطلقت تركيا وهي
الدوله الاقليميه الكبرى ذات القدرات
الماديه والتقنيه والاقتصاديه الضخمه
انذارا من الدرجه الرابعه في معيار
الكوارث ما يعني حكما طلب المساعدات
الخارجيه التي بدات بالتدفق فعلا من كل
انحاء العالم وذكر مؤشر يكفي لادراك فداحه
الخطر الذي ينطوي عليه شحو الامكانات في
شمال سوريا حيث ملايين النازحين والسكان
الفقراء المتروكين لاقدارهم دونما رعايه
من اي سلطه بل الذين لا تصلوا اليهم لقمه
الخبز ان والصلاه بغير صفقات امميه معقده
تبرمها الدول الكبرى في الامم المتحده كل
سته شهور وتتحدد بموجبها المساعدات
الغذائيه المسموح بتوريدها لمناطقهم ومن
اي المعابر تمر وكيف
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
يقال ان نوع وحجم الماساه يقتضيان النقي
عن تسييسها ويستدعيان حصر الاهتمام
بجانبها الانساني قيل ايضا ان هذا وقت
التمعن في الكارثه او التامل في ذواتنا
بدلا من التنقيب في خلفيات الحدث او
ابعاده وتلك اقوال ربما تخفف او تعزز وقع
الالم في نفوس من يراقبون المشهد على
شاشات التلفزه كل حسب وجهات نظره غير انها
لن تغير الكثير في مشاعر ام تبحث بين
الركام عن ابنها وهي تدرك ان الاليات
والمعدات اللازمه لانقاذه او انتشال جثته
قد تعذر وصولها لاسباب سياسيه او نتيجه
عوامل ترتبط بجشع صناع الماسي وشروطهم بان
يكونوا هم الاوصياء على المعونات المرسله
الى الضحايا
[موسيقى]
بتاسيس الكلام عن الزلزال اذا او من دونه
يمر الوقت الذي طالما كان من دم وصار
اليوم من هواء او من اوكسجين تبتعد لحظه
وقوع الزلزال في الزمن فتضيق مع ابتعادها
انفاس الاحياء المطبورين تحت الركام او
تتحلل جثث الميتين منهم لتتحلل في اللحظات
نفسها ايضا ارواح الواقفين فوق الركام وان
ظلت السونهم تلهج بالنشيد القديم مالنا
غيرك يا الله